As we've seen in previous lessons,
data can have its issues.
A perfect data set isn't typically
available in the real world.
Not only do we have to get the existing
data set up so that it's usable for
analysis, but we've also seen that
sometimes there are missing data and
we have to figure out
what to do with them.
Either not use them or
make something up to fill these gaps.
Another issue that we'll
explore in this lesson
is the fact that sometimes
certain records within the data
just don't seem to fit with
the data set as a whole.
If it's numeric field there may
be numbers that seem extreme, or
way too large, or small, compared
to the other values in that field.
If it's categorical data,
it might have a value that only appears
once out of a large set of data.
In statistics, the common term for
this kind of data is an outlier.
Sometimes there can be good reasons
why this data looks weird and
sometimes it may be because
the data is just wrong.
In this lesson, we're going to cover how
to recognize when outliers are present,
understand how they can
affect your model and
some common methods for
keeping that affect to a minimum.